hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to monster cliff I near the
boiler two days back when I checked it
out there was nothing but it might be a
good place to start Fred Fred is dead
okay that's new is that Fred is it is
that Fred up there Fred I thought you
were dead
stop banging around you know you're
gonna get yourself killed oh well I'm
just making all the noise in the world
bleeding all of the monsters come nibble
a little bit of a little tooth shouldn't
have smashed that bottle
well that wasn't a good sound what the
hell having their booth [ __ ] oh [ __ ]
this okay nine pump it up sis that's
quite alright so quiet I'm sure no one
will care
fifth escape the ship okay I can do that
I can do that
now oh why did I jump off it sounds very
sexual do not [ __ ] melons but you know
[ __ ] milk Oh run Oh can't run no running